[Applause]
[Laughter]
they did a great job matching the
lighting
on the green screen elements the titans
you get so tiny as it flies away you
notice that
[Laughter]
there's two opposing concepts
happening at the same time
hello welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artist react
i'm here on the couch joined by wren
likeman and sam gorski
hi hey everyone's now sleeping nico
wake the [ __ ] up because these clips
aren't what you think they are
go outside and run a mile turn up the
brightness on your phone
maximize the audio and let's watch some
clips together
let's be honest they're eating cheerios
on the toilet right now
we have some incredible clips today
we're going to be breaking them down
what we like about them what we don't
like about them
and some behind the scenes looks to
figure out what's really going on
i'm not on the menu
[Music]
oh going straight into the afterlife huh
resident evil
so this scene was requested in the
comments i had seen it before
and i we have to do it today finally
i told you i'd be bringing a few friends
you should have brought more
oh let me guess this was a 3d movie oh
definitely
resident evil afterlife in 3d
this is back right in the heart of the
era of you know 3d movies and i was
honestly kind of always a fan of 3d
movies unless they did the stupid
gimmicky stuff like oh it comes out of
the tv screen
this one's pretty janky first thing i'm
noticing
is that this actor cannot move his neck
notice how every time he's moving his
face is always straightforward he's
moving with his chest he's definitely
cast because he looks like the game
character and that's about it
what's going on here is there's two
opposing
concepts happening at the same time he's
moving super fast
and he's moving super slow
which is like are we quickly dodging the
bullets are we dodging in slow motion
and this one they're like
both a little bit there's no bullet
trails in the shot if we're looking at
just the shot out of context it's just
him going
and then disappearing to another spot
going hits or anything yeah like maybe i
had sparks or something in the
background of like
where he is shooting i guess also here
another thing that
it's not quite vfx related but it has to
do with the camera work you notice
very frequently whenever like a visual
effects shot happens they just do like a
locked off
like tripod shot so like suddenly
no longer are you using the camera work
to help emphasize the effect
or the motion or whatever and you just
you're just left with like the most raw
form
of the action on screen even just a
simple punch in
and like reanimating the shot afterwards
would have made this shot so much better
see this dodging i actually kind of like
this has
the impact that a shot like this is
supposed to have
exactly they're adding like that that
punchy distortion and
it just gives the shot energy that i
like the other shot didn't have that
energy
the most like the laziest bullet dodge
like um
[Music]
he didn't even dodge it she just missed
and she shoots again but they just like
ignore it
it's the world's longest muzzle flash
dude it's just like it
shoots and then like glitches out and
sticks in the air for a while
dude the three bullets that go by super
fast like she goes
yeah those two bullets how'd you fire
two bullets so
fast
like the double bullet like two bullets
got packed into one casing and they both
came out
oh right into the tubes
[Laughter]
there's a lot of wacky things going on
here but that's because this is based on
a video game
and there's a game cinematic that's from
the series that's really similar to this
wait really
you're saying most the choreography from
the scene is based on a game cinematic
oh my goodness it is oh but he starts
moving while the glass is distracting
and uses that time to run in
oh that was way cooler in the movie it's
like literally just a fast blur it's a
very feathered blur which doesn't look
very good
but this one it's got like directional
spikes in the blur
and it's an actual like like smoke
element too his poses are
way more dynamic and the camera's
rushing in and he's rushing in
as well as the other guys rushing and
implying aggression and confrontation
well that slide was so much more intense
like with the coat flaring out and
everything
they even had the freaking neck crack
after he like got hit
pretty crazy right seeing how like how
close this is you know i'm gonna give
i'm gonna give the filmmakers props
for actually trying to copy some of the
stuff in the game the dogs do look
pretty good the shading the contrast all
looks very realistic
i think they actually had real dogs on
the set with makeup and costumes
which is really cool and then they did
uh cg additions
i think once again it goes to show like
when you can mix practical and visual
effects
it will stand up like even now you know
10
11 years later it still stands up even
if a lot of the rest of the scene
doesn't
there's probably a whole lot of context
that we're missing there may have been a
lot of
issues on set with like you know budget
maybe they didn't have enough budget to
really
put a lot of money to make the scene
better maybe the effects artists were
behind on time
you know who knows what happened but at
the end of the day we're sitting here
having a good time watching the final
results look we've made bad stuff too
and we still watch it and laugh at it
too like we can all enjoy the process
where do you think we get these clips
from do they just come to us
like ideas randomly no actually they
come from the comments
so if there's a clip you want to see or
want us to react to let us know in the
comments below
we went to the american premiere of this
movie and we
walked away changed men it's it's like
so fundamentally different from the
anime and the manga like the characters
are completely different
the only thing that's really the same is
the fact that there's a wall and there's
some big titans
it's pretty wacky but there is some cool
stuff in it
and there's some not so cool stuff
this is actually pretty sweet i will say
the colossal titan in this movie is
pretty cool
it's a big ass puppet they made
everything around it is cg
but the colossal titan itself is this
huge
like rubbery puppet that's being
controlled by like three or four people
on a green screen
it's you probably understand that when
you have a lot of computer generated
characters it takes a lot of time and
effort
to make that a reality therefore it
costs a lot of money and i imagine this
movie didn't have that kind of budget to
do all of that so
they resorted to basically having all of
their titans
be real people
[Music]
dude the glutton is tight there he is
dude look at those prosthetic eyes
that entire eye strip there was
prosthetic to make the eyes weird okay
they're at least doing that because the
whole thing about the titans is that
they are weird
they did a great job matching the
lighting on the green screen elements
the titans that is true
that is absolutely true it doesn't look
that bad i mean that shot right there of
her like on her
knees and whatnot like common people the
angle is really good
i do think a lot of like the
pre-production on all the compositing
work is really well done
like the thought out camera placement
the placement of the lights
is incredibly important when you're
shooting green screen elements and
they're also filling the titans in slow
motion which is another layer
of like planning that you have to do you
know it's like if you're gonna okay my
actor ran from here to here in two
seconds
we're gonna film the titans at a scale
of three to one so that's gonna we're
gonna have them do that action
over the course of a two-thirds of a
second and then slow it down to be two
seconds
like it's complicated stuff and they're
doing a really good job of it like
whoever basically you know supervised
and executed these visual effects scenes
like they know their
compositing and scale and all that kind
of stuff
this little 360 in after effects right
there
yeah i'm sorry
honestly like if we were to make an
attack on titan thing it'd probably be
about the same
like i'd be pretty pleased if it looked
this good but at the same time just the
mere nature of
what they do isn't something that you
can really replicate in real life that's
the whole reason why it starts as an
anime you can achieve those things
yeah it's like such inorganic motion for
like people to actually perform
okay but it doesn't make any sense
okay anyways
there we go that's a cool [ __ ] that's a
question there we go that's a sweet shot
this is we're in full power rangers now
yeah
like this is basically just power
rangers with like flesh costumes
oh we think that that's about this you
don't do a power rangers action scene
without a double drop kick action move
and he did it and it's just like
her reaction is your reaction it's the
quintessential move
i mean the funny thing is like attack on
titan is at its core
power rangers ultraman voltron thing
it's just flesh mechs
yeah straight up they're flush max and
like you're like oh my god it's just
it's the same old thing with a new twist
but that's how you do it you know that's
how you write stories
i mean honestly the visual effects in
this movie are totally good enough for
an attack on titan movie if only the
movie itself had stuck to like some of
the story ideas
that actually made attack on titan
special
we have 62.9 percent of you guys are
subscribed
thank you for subscribing i appreciate
it that is you know what i'm not gonna
call out the people who are not
subscribed all of you that did subscribe
i see you and i thank you except i see
you
kevin it's about time to subscribe we
know you're not subscribed to kevin
kevin i wasn't going to mention it but i
noticed too classic kevin
you should let me go
this movie is called the day after
tomorrow no
no that's war of the worlds the war of
the world wait no god dang it
this movie is called the day the earth
stood still the other kiana reeves movie
it's time for some helicopter vfx jank
let's do it
as a buzzword you notice that
oh my goodness
[Laughter]
she shrinks what could have happened
here and this is random speculation you
know they have a
film element like helicopters here okay
and i'm gonna go to the end of the shot
the helicopter is scaled down about 50
so i'll scale her down about 50 and
maybe it kind of fits the thing is
when something's moving away from you in
3d space it gets smaller you know
in a two-dimensional composition but
it's not a linear like shrinkage it
works more like a curve so like
it'll shrink down quickly and then
little by little shrinks slower and
slower
so maybe there's a mistimed shrinkage
and like she's linearly scaling and the
helicopters
it's like an inverse yeah inverse
i love this helicopter cockpit point of
view also it's just like
it's just really shaky helicopters are
not that shaky
helicopters vibrate but they're not like
going around
permission to engage also the thing that
you always see with like fake infrared
view
is like the infrared following the light
like his hands
they should be they should be orange
like his faces yes
they actually do have the the legend
there so you can right there i'm looking
at it they're implying his hands are
40 degrees his face is at the right
temperature yeah his face is at the
right temperature and then his suit
is like arctic like legit
zero degrees like freezing temperature
and his hairline
is like searing hot
oh hold up there so as these two
helicopters are approaching it's
a tracking issue and just watching it
first go it looks off
somebody thought you know what shaky
camera
let's just shake the camera when we film
it so what happens when you shake the
camera well now you got to go through
and track everything and track the shake
back in
but then they have this other object
which is the helicopter that they want
to
see through the cockpit window but
you're beholden to the motion that you
got on set because you've filmed it with
a shaky camera
and they're like well we can't have that
helicopter shaking all over the place
can we
we need to see it and now you have a
totally disconnected graphic that's not
tracked into the scene at all
you have a background that's not really
tracked to the shaky camera either
it's three levels of independent motion
anyways i'm just ragging on this movie
because it's a
easy target that being said this movie
does have some really cool effects in it
have you guys seen the like the whole
trailer getting dissolved by the
nanobots
the camera maintains its momentum as it
follows the truck and the truck
literally like disintegrates
and pieces of it break off before those
pieces disintegrate and then that cloud
that swarm of nanobots just like floats
away i love it when cg is used to do
like more abstract things like having a
truck disintegrate
this is a great visual effects shot yeah
no this isn't yeah this is amazing
the nanobot stuff is really cool but
definitely feels like there's some time
and budget constraints for the other
shots and they get a little rough
well what usually happens with movies
like this is that there's a bit of a
priority breakdown for like what shots
get the most love you know
i bet it was probably just one company
that did all of these shots and they
were the priciest company
and that's where most of the budget went
to and then they had to sprinkle the
rest of the budget to
everyone else doing all the other
effects in the movie yeah that would be
my guess
everyone freeze it's an emergency green
screen
hoodie which is now on sale at corridor
digital
dot store inspired by the emergency
green screen blankets
we've now realized wait a second what if
you want your green screen with you
all the time now before you skip look
you're probably saying hey sam i'm
already wearing clothes why do i need
new ones well let me tell you why first
off just take a look at this beautiful
boss town dynamics design did you know
this is one of the fastest selling
designs in our stores history
well they're back and ready for you to
pick one up not to mention
it's almost summer a hawaiian shirt is
gonna look sweet on you and our custom
hawaiian shirts
are perfect for letting everyone know
that you're in the fun you're into
partying also
you can render out a cool shot and once
again this is not
all we offer we have tons of other great
things to show your support
for the channel water bottles hats
jackets
more green screen gear these sweaters
super comfy
every single person who has purchased a
hoodie you can you can go
straight to them and they'll tell you
it's one of the most comfortable hoodies
they've ever worn
head on over to corridor digital dot
store and pick one up
[Music]
now
wow okay that was that was a lot more
roasting than i anticipated but that was
some fun roasting if you guys worked on
any of these movies i'm sorry but
hopefully you aren't upset
thanks for watching we appreciate it
we'll be back here next week with
another episode of visual effects artist
react until then
subscribe so you don't miss out hit that
doorbell
ding dong that's the sound of you who
has just subscribed
thank you ding dong ding ding